I've always thought of Education as the
ultimate Legacy if you die and you leave
no education to anyone else would a
waste of a life I don't know the guy who
invented wallpaper windows glassic I
don't know any of that stuff Edison made
the light bulb and then we were like hey
if we put 100 little ones in a row we
have a screen everything we have is
always piggybacking on past humans who
we don't know the names of I
foolheartedly expect to be another human
that other people catapult off of that
they all forget me I'm just trying to
document as much as I can to try and
pass on as much as is useful to other
people and I think that when I die that
will be what I am proud of